Michael Wolfe the author of fire and
fury inside the Trump White House is
with us this morning good morning
Michael good morning thank you for
having me a lot has happened since
details of your book just came out the
president is to say the least the
president in response has felt the need
to describe himself as a stable genius
based on your reporting are there people
inside the White House talking about
trying to remove him from office they're
not talking about trying to remove him
from office they're wondering what's
going to there the people in the White
House are like everybody else in the
country what's going to happen here we
don't know from day to day this is this
is for them as for everyone an
extraordinary experience and and I think
that they certainly questioned what's
going to happen here like everybody else
there are many moments in which the 25th
amendment has come up the 25th amendment
in which which gives the cabinet the
ability to remove the president and they
don't say they don't say the the cabinet
is going to remove the president but
they do say things things like this is
well this is a little 25th amendment in
here well it's interesting because you
say that Bannon was going around the
White House saying that there was a 33%
chance that the president would be
impeached a 33% chance that he would
resign under threat of the 25th
amendment correct and a 33 and a third
percent chance that he would limp to the
finish line but a 0% chance that he
would have another term president Trump
yesterday said the book is a fake book
he said you are totally discredited as
an author is everything in the book true
everything in the book is true in your
response to that well I'm waiting for a
nickname where's my nickname he did call
it a work of fiction Stephen Miller
continued that narrative over the
weekend there had been reports I can I
can reliably say Donald Trump has never
read a work of fiction so one person who
appears on almost every page of this
book is hope X in terms of what she saw
and what she was aware of and
participated in how big of an impact
would she have in the Moller
investigation if in fact she did
cooperate with him and how worried
should the president be I I think huge
hope is at the center of this
administration I mean one of the cure I
mean she's really one of the curious
figures she really begins as something
like an intern in the or a very
low-level person in the campaign and
funkotron beforehand that's what she was
Ivanka Trump right she was she was a
fashion PR person and and then she was
seconded to the campaign and she became
very close to the candidate and then
very close to the president the United
States and now for all intent and
purpose
she is the president's senior most
advisor did you speak with any members
of the president's cabinet for this book
I did not you did not I did not and did
you speak with the vice president I did
not when was the last time you spoke
with the president for this book you
know as I said all along here in the and
the White House seems very focused on on
on this and I've spent about three hours
talking to the president over the course
of the of the campaign the transition
and in the White House but the the the
important point I want to make is that
this book is not about my impression of
the president I came into this with no
agenda I continue to have no political
you're not fair enough but it's like a
running narrative like as you say you
were a semi-permanent
spot you were a fly on the wall and the
White House it does also read like your
main source is Steve Bannon would it be
correct to sort of say that it would be
not correct he's a very large source
here but there are many many many you
know there are it's worse than anybody
thought that he's mentally unstable that
he's not that he's an idiot okay I
didn't say this isn't I did not say he's
mentally unstable
I would not be qualified to do this I'd
say I have merely described and mostly
not not
my impressions the impressions of other
people of the people he deals with you
for this book at all well I think he
probably had no idea he was speaking to
me for this book when I would meet the
president in the White House we would we
would chat as though we were friends and
and that was what was you to greet
someone and say hello I mean that's not
it that's not a journalistic expertise
ed three hours you'd spend three hours
as well I through the course at first I
have sat down with the president for an
extended extended periods of interviews
but there's other periods in which in
which and that's essentially what he's
saying there should they're trying to
parse this and saying oh I didn't know
that I was speaking to him when I saw
him in the White House as an as an
intern clarify the White House says the
last time they have a record of you
meeting with President Trump was
February 2017 that's just barely a
hundred days into his presidency did you
interview him after that date did let's
let's separate this out I interviewed
him at that point after that we would we
would we would speak I'm sure he didn't
think they were interviews and and in
all fairness he might say I was not
being interviewed how much do you think
things have changed since John Kelly
became chief of staff I think that they
well they've obviously changed a lot
there's there's and it's gone bannon's
gone previous gone Spicer's gone so
these sources so so the the the core of
the of the of the White House of that of
that first the first six months the core
of that staff is gone so a lot has lot
has changed given the staffing of the
White House the thing that has not
changed of course is Donald Trump
Michael Wolff we're at a time thank you
so much for joining us thank you